SO PEOPLE
WOULDN'T REDEEM THE REBATE.
BUT REALLY IN THE END,
WHAT I REALIZED IS THAT
MORE IMPORTANT THAN ANY OF THIS
IS FRIENDSHIP.
- OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
- AND DOING THIS
I MADE SOME VERY GOOD FRIENDS.
RAY PREMUS
WAS ONE OF THEM.
- WHO?
- RAY PREMUS.
- OH.
- HE WAS WILLING
TO DRINK PEE.
- PEE?
- YEAH.
- WHOSE PEE?
- NO, JUST ANYONE'S PEE.
- ANYONE'S PEE?
- HE SAYS THERE'S NO GERMS.
- MAYBE THEY CAN DRINK
MY GRANDSON'S PEE.
IT'S VERY CLEAN.
YEAH?
- WHY--
- BECAUSE IT'S CLEAN.
WHY DRINK MY PEE
OR YOUR PEE?
- YOU'RE PROMOTING
YOUR GRANDSON'S PEE.
- I AM PROMOTING BECAUSE
GRANDSON'S PEE SOMETIMES HELPS.
IT REALLY HELPS.
- HAVE YOU DRANK
YOUR GRANDSON'S PEE?
- YEAH.
- WHY?
- I WAS SCARED.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN
YOU WERE SCARED?
- YEAH, SOMETIMES
YOU'RE SCARED FOR SOMETHING.
- WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
- ACCIDENT OR SOMETHING,
YOU DRINK
THE GRANDSON'S PEE,
AND IT'S GONNA HELP YOU.
- I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY DOES IT HELP YOU IF
YOU DRINK YOUR GRANDSON'S PEE?
- THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY,
YEAH.
- WHO SAYS THAT?
- MY GRANDMA.
- YOUR GRANDMA SAID--
- LONG TIME AGO, YEAH.
- YOU DRINK YOUR GRANDSON'S
PEE IF YOU GET SCARED?
- NOT GRANDSON'S.
ANY LITTLE KID.
- YOU DRINK ANY--
- NOT OVER AGE OF FIVE,
BECAUSE BEFORE
OVER AGE OF FIVE,
IT'S TERRIBLE.
- I HAVE NEVER--
- I AM SERIOUS ABOUT IT.
- BUT WHY--
- YEAH, IF YOU'RE SCARED,
YOU DRINK
THE SMALL CHILD'S PEE.
IT HELPS.
I HEARD FROM MY GRANDMA.
YOU CAN ASK YOUR PARENTS
OR GRANDPARENTS.
MAYBE THEY TELL YOU TOO.
- I WILL ASK, I GUESS.
- THANK YOU
FOR GIVING THIS IDEA.